Hi, I’m Carrie Anne, and welcome to Crash
Course Computer Science!
Today, let’s start by thinking about how
important vision can be.
Most people rely on it to prepare food, walk
around obstacles, read street signs, watch
videos like this, and do hundreds of other
tasks.
Vision is the highest bandwidth sense, and
it provides a firehose of information about
the state of the world and how to act on it.
For this reason, computer scientists have
been trying to give computers vision for half
a century, birthing the sub-field of computer
vision.
Its goal is to give computers the ability
to extract high-level understanding from digital
images and videos.
As everyone with a digital camera or smartphone
knows, computers are already really good at
capturing photos with incredible fidelity
and detail – much better than humans in fact.
But as computer vision professor Fei-Fei Li
recently said, “Just like to hear is the
not the same as to listen.
To take pictures is not the same as to see.”
INTRO
As a refresher, images on computers are most
often stored as big grids of pixels.
Each pixel is defined by a color, stored as
a combination of three additive primary colors:
red, green and blue.
By combining different intensities of these
three colors, what’s called a RGB value,
we can represent any color.
Perhaps the simplest computer vision algorithm
– and a good place to start – is to track
a colored object, like a bright pink ball.
The first thing we need to do is record the
ball’s color.
For that, we’ll take the RGB value of the
centermost pixel.
With that value saved, we can give a computer
program an image, and ask it to find the pixel
with the closest color match.
An algorithm like this might start in the
upper right corner, and check each pixel,
one at time, calculating the difference from
our target color.
Now, having looked at every pixel, the best
match is very likely a pixel from our ball.
We’re not limited to running this algorithm
on a single photo; we can do it for every
frame in a video, allowing us to track the
ball over time.
Of course, due to variations in lighting,
shadows, and other effects, the ball on the
field is almost certainly not going to be
the exact same RGB value as our target color,
but merely the closest match.
In more extreme cases, like at a game at night,
the tracking might be poor.
And if one of the team's jerseys used the
same color as the ball, our algorithm would
get totally confused.
For these reasons, color marker tracking and
similar algorithms are rarely used, unless
the environment can be tightly controlled.
This color tracking example was able to search
pixel-by-pixel, because colors are stored
inside of single pixels.
But this approach doesn’t work for features
larger than a single pixel, like edges of
objects, which are inherently made up of many
pixels.
To identify these types of features in images,
computer vision algorithms have to consider
small regions of pixels, called patches.
As an example, let’s talk about an algorithm
that finds vertical edges in a scene, let’s
say to help a drone navigate safely through
a field of obstacles.
To keep things simple, we’re going to convert
our image into grayscale, although most algorithms
can handle color.
Now let’s zoom into one of these poles to
see what an edge looks like up close.
We can easily see where the left edge of the
pole starts, because there’s a change in
color that persists across many pixels vertically.
We can define this behavior more formally
by creating a rule that says the likelihood
of a pixel being a vertical edge is the magnitude
of the difference in color between some pixels
to its left and some pixels to its right.
The bigger the color difference between these
two sets of pixels, the more likely the pixel
is on an edge.
If the color difference is small, it’s probably
not an edge at all.
The mathematical notation for this operation
looks like this – it’s called a kernel
or filter.
It contains the values for a pixel-wise multiplication, the sum of which is saved into the center pixel.
Let’s see how this works for our example
pixel.
I’ve gone ahead and labeled all of the pixels
with their grayscale values.
Now, we take our kernel, and center it over
our pixel of interest.
This specifies what each pixel value underneath
should be multiplied by.
Then, we just add up all those numbers.
In this example, that gives us 147.
That becomes our new pixel value.
This operation, of applying a kernel to a
patch of pixels, is call a convolution.
Now let’s apply our kernel to another pixel.
In this case, the result is 1.
Just 1.
In other words, it’s a very small color
difference, and not an edge.
If we apply our kernel to every pixel in the
photo, the result looks like this, where the
highest pixel values are where there are strong
vertical edges.
Note that horizontal edges, like those platforms
in the background, are almost invisible.
If we wanted to highlight those features,
we’d have to use a different kernel – one
that’s sensitive to horizontal edges.
Both of these edge enhancing kernels are called
Prewitt Operators, named after their inventor.
These are just two examples of a huge variety
of kernels, able to perform many different
image transformations.
For example, here’s a kernel that sharpens
images.
And here’s a kernel that blurs them.
Kernels can also be used like little image
cookie cutters that match only certain shapes.
So, our edge kernels looked for image patches
with strong differences from right to left
or up and down.
But we could also make kernels that are good
at finding lines, with edges on both sides.
And even islands of pixels surrounded by contrasting
colors.
These types of kernels can begin to characterize
simple shapes.
For example, on faces, the bridge of the nose
tends to be brighter than the sides of the
nose, resulting in higher values for line-sensitive
kernels.
Eyes are also distinctive – a dark circle
sounded by lighter pixels – a pattern other
kernels are sensitive to.
When a computer scans through an image, most
often by sliding around a search window, it
can look for combinations of features indicative
of a human face.
Although each kernel is a weak face detector
by itself, combined, they can be quite accurate.
It’s unlikely that a bunch of face-like
features will cluster together if they’re
not a face.
This was the basis of an early and influential
algorithm called Viola-Jones Face Detection.
Today, the hot new algorithms on the block
are Convolutional Neural Networks.
We talked about neural nets last episode,
if you need a primer.
In short, an artificial neuron – which is
the building block of a neural network – takes
a series of inputs, and multiplies each by
a specified weight, and then sums those values
all together.
This should sound vaguely familiar, because
it’s a lot like a convolution.
In fact, if we pass a neuron 2D pixel data,
rather than a one-dimensional list of inputs,
it’s exactly like a convolution.
The input weights are equivalent to kernel
values, but unlike a predefined kernel, neural
networks can learn their own useful kernels
that are able to recognize interesting features
in images.
Convolutional Neural Networks use banks of
these neurons to process image data, each
outputting a new image, essentially digested
by different learned kernels.
These outputs are then processed by subsequent
layers of neurons, allowing for convolutions
on convolutions on convolutions.
The very first convolutional layer might find
things like edges, as that’s what a single
convolution can recognize, as we’ve already
discussed.
The next layer might have neurons that convolve
on those edge features to recognize simple
shapes, comprised of edges, like corners.
A layer beyond that might convolve on those
corner features, and contain neurons that
can recognize simple objects, like mouths
and eyebrows.
And this keeps going, building up in complexity,
until there’s a layer that does a convolution
that puts it together: eyes, ears, mouth,
nose, the whole nine yards, and says “ah
ha, it’s a face!”
Convolutional neural networks aren’t required
to be many layers deep, but they usually are,
in order to recognize complex objects and
scenes.
That’s why the technique is considered deep
learning.
Both Viola-Jones and Convolutional Neural
Networks can be applied to many image recognition
problems, beyond faces, like recognizing handwritten
text, spotting tumors in CT scans and monitoring
traffic flow on roads.
But we’re going to stick with faces.
Regardless of what algorithm was used, once
we’ve isolated a face in a photo, we can
apply more specialized computer vision algorithms
to pinpoint facial landmarks, like the tip
of the nose and corners of the mouth.
This data can be used for determining things
like if the eyes are open, which is pretty
easy once you have the landmarks – it’s
just the distance between points.
We can also track the position of the eyebrows;
their relative position to the eyes can be
an indicator of surprise, or delight.
Smiles are also pretty straightforward to
detect based on the shape of mouth landmarks.
All of this information can be interpreted
by emotion recognition algorithms, giving
computers the ability to infer when you’re
happy, sad, frustrated, confused and so on.
In turn, that could allow computers to intelligently
adapt their behavior... maybe offer tips when
you’re confused, and not ask to install
updates when you’re frustrated.
This is just one example of how vision can
give computers the ability to be context sensitive,
that is, aware of their surroundings.
And not just the physical surroundings – like
if you're at work or on a train – but also
your social surroundings – like if you’re
in a formal business meeting versus a friend’s
birthday party.
You behave differently in those surroundings, and so should computing devices, if they’re smart.
Facial landmarks also capture the geometry
of your face, like the distance between your
eyes and the height of your forehead.
This is one form of biometric data, and it
allows computers with cameras to recognize
you.
Whether it’s your smartphone automatically
unlocking itself when it sees you, or governments
tracking people using CCTV cameras, the applications
of face recognition seem limitless.
There have also been recent breakthroughs
in landmark tracking for hands and whole bodies,
giving computers the ability to interpret
a user’s body language, and what hand gestures
they’re frantically waving at their internet
connected microwave.
As we’ve talked about many times in this
series, abstraction is the key to building
complex systems, and the same is true in computer
vision.
At the hardware level, you have engineers
building better and better cameras, giving
computers improved sight with each passing
year, which I can’t say for myself.
Using that camera data, you have computer
vision algorithms crunching pixels to find
things like faces and hands.
And then, using output from those algorithms,
you have even more specialized algorithms
for interpreting things like user facial expression
and hand gestures.
On top of that, there are people building
novel interactive experiences, like smart
TVs and intelligent tutoring systems, that
respond to hand gestures and emotion.
Each of these levels are active areas of research,
with breakthroughs happening every year.
And that’s just the tip of the iceberg.
Today, computer vision is everywhere – whether
it’s barcodes being scanned at stores, self-driving
cars waiting at red lights, or snapchat filters
superimposing mustaches.
And, the most exciting thing is that computer
scientists are really just getting started,
enabled by recent advances in computing, like
super fast GPUs.
Computers with human-like ability to see is
going to totally change how we interact with them.
Of course, it’d also be nice if they could
hear and speak, which we’ll discuss next
week.
I’ll see you then.